[Music]  today Morgan Freeman did you hear about  this Morgan Freeman gave Barack Obama a  1 million dollar donation 1 million  dollar gonna hook up on the app and  actually here's the interesting thing  Morgan Freeman went even further and  made his own campaign ad take a look I'm  Morgan Freeman supporting Barack Obama  because he possesses the measure of  vision our great nation hungers for and  I oppose Mitt Romney because he's a no  caffeine drinking dog cos trappin weird  name given Android so rich each of its  493 houses is equipped with a bidet that  cleanses his bum with thousand-dollar  bills  Morgan Freeman and I am off my  medications  [Applause]  [Music]